here in the u.s the department of
homeland security is warning of a
potential troubling escalation and
tactics from right-wing extremists
catherine herridge has more on this and
she joins us from washington catherine
we understand the power grid could be a
target
good morning according to the
intelligence report obtained by cbs news
these groups have developed credible and
specific plans to attack the power grid
since at least 2020 as a way to disrupt
the country and the ability of
government to operate the report warns
extremists adhering to a range of
ideologies will likely continue to plot
and encourage physical attacks against
power networks which include more than 6
400 plants and nearly a half million
miles of high voltage lines while the
bulletin emphasized small scale attacks
are unlikely to cause widespread power
loss it may cause disruption to critical
infrastructure like hospitals and police
departments homeland security noted
several indicators including online
chatter while the report does not
suggest an imminent threat the homeland
security secretary has warned lone wolf
actors and small bands of extremists are
among the greatest domestic threat
because they are hard to detect disrupt
and can mobilize quickly
all right catherine got it thank you